for this video I'm doing something a
little different I got the chance to sit
down with Steven Strogatz
and record a conversation for those of
you who don't know Steve is a
mathematician at Cornell he's the author
of several popular math books and a
frequent contributor to among other
things
radio lab and the New York Times to put
it shortly he's one of the great mass
communicators of math in our time in our
conversation we talked about a lot of
things but it was all centering around
this one very famous problem in the
history of math they brought Kista crone
and for the first two thirds or so of
the video I'm just going to play some of
that conversation we lay out the problem
talk about some of its history and go
through the solution by Johann Bernoulli
from the 17th century after that I'm
going to show this proof that Steve
showed me it's by a modern mathematician
mark Levy and it gives a certain
geometric insight to Johann Bernoulli's
original solution then at the very end I
have a little challenge for you we
should probably start off with just
defining the problem itself okay all
right you want me to take a crack at
that yeah go for it okay yeah so it's
this complicated word
first of all brick ista Crone that comes
from 2g I have to check are those Latin
or Greek words I think I'm pretty sure
they're Greek okay so Greek words for
the shortest time and it refers to the
question that was posed by one of their
Bernoulli brothers by Johann Bernoulli
if you imagine like a shoot and there's
a particle moving down a chute being
pulled by gravity what's the path of the
chute that connects two points so that
it goes from point A to point B in the
shortest amount of time I think what I
like most about this problem is that
it's relatively easy to describe
qualitatively what you're going for you
know you want the path to be short
something like a straight line but you
want the object to get going fast
which requires starting steeply and that
adds length to your line but making this
quantitative and actually finding the
balance with a specific curve it's not
at all obvious and makes for a really
interesting problem it is it's a really
interesting
I mean most people when they first hear
it assume that the shortest path will
give the shortest time that the straight
line is the best but but as you say it
it can help to build up some steam by
rolling straight down at first or not
necessarily rolling I mean it you could
picture it sliding that doesn't really
matter how we phrase it but so Galileo
had thought about this himself much
earlier than Johann Bernoulli in 1638
and Galileo thought that an arc of a
circle would be the best thing so he had
the idea that a bit of curvature might
help and it turns out that the arc of
the circle is not the right answer it's
good but there are better solutions and
the history of real solution starts with
Johann Bernoulli posing this as a
challenge so that's then in June of 1696
and he posed it as a challenge really to
the mathematical world at that time for
him that meant two mathematicians of
Europe and in particular he was very
concerned to show off that he was
smarter than his brother you know so he
had a brother Jacob and the two of them
were quite bitter rivals actually both
tremendous mathematicians but Johann
Bernoulli fancied himself the greatest
mathematician of his era not just better
than his brother but you know I think he
thought that he might be better than
than Leibniz who was alive at the time
and Isaac Newton who was by then a sort
of an old man I mean more or less
retired from doing math and Newton was
the warden of the mint be something like
secretary of the Treasury nowadays and
Newton shows him up right he stays up
all night and solves it even though it
took johann bernoulli two weeks to solve
that right that's the great story that
Newton was shown the problem wasn't
really pleased to be challenged
especially by somebody that he
considered beneath him I mean he
considered pretty much everybody beneath
him but but yeah Newton stayed up all
night solved it and then sent it in
anonymously to the Philosophical
Transactions the journal at the time and
it was published anonymously and so
Newton complained in a letter to a
friend of his he said I do not love to
be done dand teased by foreigners about
mathematical thing
so he didn't enjoy this challenge but he
did solve it
the famous legend is that johann
bernoulli on seeing this anonymous
solution said I recognized the lion by
his claw I don't know if that's true but
it's a great story everyone loves to
tell that story and I suspect part of
the reason that Johann was so eager to
challenge other mathematicians like
Newton is he secretly knew that his own
solution was unusually clever maybe we
should start going into what he does
mm-hmm yes he imagines that to solve the
problem you let like take care of it for
you because Verma in the early 1600s had
shown that you could you could state the
way that light travels whether bouncing
off of a mirror or refracting from air
into water where it bends or going
through a lens all the motion of light
could be understood by saying that light
takes whatever path gets it from point A
to point B in the shortest time which is
a really awesome perspective when you
think about it because usually you think
very locally in terms of what happens to
a particle at each specific point this
steps back and looks at all possible
paths and says nature chooses the best
one yes it is it's a beautiful and as
you say really an awe-inspiring
mental shift for some people literally
awe-inspiring in the sense that it had
religious overtones that somehow nature
is imbued with this property of doing
the most efficient thing Oh interesting
but leaving that aside you know you
could just say it's an empirical fact
that that is how Mike behaves and so
Johan Bernoulli's idea was to then use
Verma's principle of least time and say
let's pretend that instead of a particle
sliding down a chute it's light
traveling through media of different
index of refraction meaning that the
light would go at different speeds as it
as it successively went sort of down the
chute and I think before we dive into
that case we should look at some so at
this point in the conversation we talked
for a while about Snell's law this is a
result in physics that describes how
light bends when it goes from one
material into another where it's speed
changes
I made a separate video out of this
talking about how you can prove it using
pheromones principle together with a
very neat argument using imaginary
constant tension Springs but for now all
you need to know is the statement of
Snell's law itself when a beam of light
passes from one medium into another and
you consider the angle that it makes
with a line perpendicular to the
boundary between those two materials the
sine of that angle divided by the speed
of light
stays constant as you move from one
medium to the next
so what Johann Bernoulli does is find a
neat way to take advantage of that fact
this sine of theta over V stays constant
FASTA crown is for the broadcast
Chrome's problem when he thinks about
what's happening with the particles
sliding down the chute he notices that
by conservation of energy
the velocity that the particle has will
be proportional to the square root of
the distance from the top and just to
spell that out a little bit more the
loss in potential energy is its mass
times the gravitational constant times y
that distance from the top and when you
set that equal to the kinetic energy
one-half times MV squared and you
rearrange the velocity V will indeed end
up being proportional to the square root
of Y mm-hmm yes so so that then gives
him the idea about let's imagine glass
of many different layers each with a
different velocity characteristic for
the light in it the velocity in the
first one is V one and the next one is V
two and the next one is V three and
these are all going to be proportional
to the square root of Y 1 or Y 2 or Y 3
and in principle you should be thinking
about a limiting process where you have
infinitely many infinitely thin layers
and this is kind of a continuous change
for the speed of light and so so then
his question is if light is always
instantaneously obeying Snell's law as
it goes from one medium to the next so
that V over sine theta is always a
constant as I move from one layer to the
next what is that path where you know
such that these tangent lines are always
instantaneously obeying
Snell's law and for the record we should
probably just state exactly what that
property is okay so the conclusion that
Johan made was that if you look at
whatever the time minimizing curve is
and you take any point on that curve the
sine of the angle between the tangent
line at that point and the vertical
divided by the square root of the
vertical distance between that point and
the start of the curve that's going to
be some constant independent of the
point that you chose and when you don't
run Bernoulli first saw this correct me
if I'm wrong he just recognized it as
the differential equation for a cycloid
the shape traced by the point on the rim
of a rolling wheel but it's not obvious
certainly not obvious to me why this
sine of theta over square root Y
property has anything to do with rolling
wheels it's it's not at all obvious but
this is again the genius of Mark levy to
the rescue do you want to say a few
words about mark levy yeah well mark
levy is a very clever as well as a very
nice guy who's a friend of mine and a
terrific mathematician at Penn State who
has written a book called the
mathematical mechanic in which he uses
principles of mechanics and more
generally physics to solve all kinds of
math problems that is rather than math
in the service of science at science in
the service of math and as an example of
the kinds of clever things that he does
he recently published a little note very
short showing that if you look at the
geometry of a cycloid just drawing the
correct lines in the right places that
that this principle of velocity over
sine theta being constant is is built-in
to the motion of the cycloid itself
so in that conversation we never
actually talked about the details of the
proof itself it's kind of a hard thing
to do without visuals but I think a lot
of you out there enjoy seeing the math
and not just talking about the math it's
also a really elegant little piece of
geometry so I'm going to go through it
here
imagine a wheel rolling on the ceiling
and picture a point P on the rim of that
wheel mark Livi's first insight was that
the point where the wheel touches the
ceiling that I'll call C acts as this
instantaneous center of rotation for the
trajectory of P it's as if for that
moment P is on the end of a pendulum
whose base is at C since the tangent
line of any circle is always
perpendicular to the radius the tangent
line of the cycloid path of P is
perpendicular to the line P see this
gives us a right angle inside of the
circle and any right triangle inscribed
in a circle must have the diameter as
its hypotenuse so from that you can
conclude that the tangent line always
intersects the bottom of the circle now
let theta be the angle between this
tangent line and the vertical we get a
pair of similar triangles which I'll
just show on the screen
you can see that the length of PC is the
diameter times sine of theta using the
second similar triangle this length
times sine of theta again gives the
distance between P and the ceiling the
distance that we were calling Y earlier
rearranging this we see that sine of
theta divided by the square root of Y is
equal to one divided by the square root
of the diameter since the diameter of a
circle of course stays constant
throughout the rotation this implies
that the sine of theta divided by square
root of Y is constant on a cycloid and
that's exactly the Snell's law property
that we're looking for so when you
combine yohan Bernoulli's insight with
this little geometry proof that's the
cleverest solution of the bhaktas de
chrome that I've ever seen
and I could call it done here but given
that the whole history of this problem
started with a challenge that Johann
Bernoulli posed I want to finish things
off with a little challenge of my own
when I was playing around with the
equations of a cycloid something
interesting popped out consider an
object sliding down the cycloid due to
gravity and think about where it is
along the curve as a function of time
now think about how the curve is defined
as this trajectory of the point on a rim
of a rotating wheel how might you tweak
the rate at which the wheel rotates so
that when the object starts sliding the
marked point on the rim of the wheel
always stays fixed to that sliding
object
do you start rotating it slowly and
increase its speed if so according to
what function it turns out the wheel
will rotate at a constant rate which is
surprising this means the gravity pulls
you along a cycloid in precisely the
same way that a constantly rotating
wheel would the warm up part of this
challenge is just confirmed this for
yourself it's kind of fun to see how it
follows out of the equations but this
got me thinking if we look back at our
original broadcast Ekron problem asking
about the path of fastest descend
between two given points
maybe there's a slick way to reframe our
thinking how would it look if instead of
describing the trajectory of a sliding
object in terms of its x and y
coordinates we described it in terms of
the angle that the velocity vector makes
as a function of time I mean you can
imagine defining a curve by having an
object start sliding then turning a knob
to determine the angle at which its
sliding at each point in time always
being pulled by gravity if you describe
the angle of the knob as a function of
time you are in fact uniquely describing
a curve you're basically using a
differential equation since what's given
is the slope as a function of some other
parameter in this case time so what's
interesting here is that when you look
at the solution of the Protista cone
problem not in the XY plane but in the t
theta plane where T is time theta is the
angle of the path all of the broad
keister cone solutions are straight
lines
that is to say theta increases at a
constant rate with respect to T when the
solution of a curve minimization problem
is a straight line it's highly
suggestive that there's some way to view
it as a shortest path problem here it's
not so straightforward since the
boundary conditions that your object
start at a point a and end at a point B
in the XY space doesn't just look like
going from one point to another in the
theta T space nevertheless my challenge
to you is this can you find another
solution to the broad Kista Crone
problem by explaining why it must be the
case that a time minimizing trajectory
when represented in t theta space
like a straight line